la parole est à notre collègue Olivier
Pacaud pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur le ministre dans le
calendrier révolutionnaire nous sommes
en pluvios c'est le mois de la pluie et
il pleut des annonces de fermeture de
classe partout dans le pays surtout en
zone rurale alors avec 59 milliards de
budget 6 et demi pour cent de haut on ne
peut que déplorer ses coupes sombres
2000 postes en moins certes la
démographie scolaire connaît une baisse
continue certes cette revalorisation
enfin ce budget conséquent permettra une
revalorisation indispensable des
rémunérations des enseignants mais alors
que tous les classements internationaux
toutes les évaluations nationales alerte
sur la fragilisation de du niveau global
des élèves alors que vous vantez les
vertus des effectifs réduits la place
des doubler où est la cohérence
pédagogique et surtout où est la justice
territoriale quand à quelques kilomètres
quelques hectomètres parfois ici on va
fermer une classe parce qu'avec 22
gamins ils sont trop nombreux et à côté
on va se réjouir d'avoir 12 gamins dans
une classe dédoublée pour plus
d'efficacité je le rappelle 70% des
élèves qui relèvent de l'éducation
prioritaire se trouve en zone rurale ou
dans des quartiers qui ne sont pas
concernés monsieur le ministre ma
question elle est simple la ruralité
est-elle devenue la variable
d'ajustement de vos politiques
éducatives
pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse c'est pas un
peu de la
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Paco vous l'avez dit la
démographie scolaire connaît une baisse
importante depuis plusieurs années une
baisse qui va à s'accentuer au rythme de
90 000 à 100 000 élèves de moins chaque
année nous prévoyons une baisse donc de
d'environ 500 000 élèves d'ici à la fin
du quinquennat dans votre département de
l'Oise par exemple ce sont
1367 élèves que l'on va compter en moins
à la prochaine rentrée dans ce contexte
de baisse démographique le taux
d'encadrement c'est à dire le ratio
entre professeurs et élèves s'améliore
depuis plusieurs années il va continuer
à s'améliorer par exemple dans l'Oise il
y a en moyenne
21,5% 21,5 élèves par classe et cette
moyenne va s'améliorer légèrement
l'année prochaine nous avons créé ces
dernières années sans deux postes de
professeur dans l'Oise pour une baisse
de
6631 élèves dans le budget 2023 nous
avons comme vous l'avez dit donner la
priorité à la revalorisation des
professeurs parce que monsieur le
sénateur à quoi sert-il de créer des
postes si nous ne pouvons pas pourvoir
les postes la question est donc d'abord
de pourvoir les postes que nous créons
avant de les multiplier sans que cela
est un effet sur le terrain quant aux
fermetures que vous évoquez nous ne le
faisons pas de manière arithmétique bien
au contraire dans chaque département les
dazaines sont au début du processus de
préparation de la rentrée 2023 avec les
élus locaux ils travaillent pour
identifier les situations sensibles et
je suis particulièrement sensible
moi-même à la situation des zones
rurales et des écoles rurales
de manière à faire des ajustements en
juin et également en août à la fin août
à ce stade rien n'est définitivement
arrêté et je serai heureux d'en reparler
avec vous
monsieur Paco oui merci d'avoir juste à
la fin
évoquer la ruralité parce que un des
gros problèmes de l'éducation nationale
mais même des politiques publiques
depuis des années c'est l'oubli de ces
territoires en 1947 Jean-François
gravier publié Paris et le désert
français depuis 2017 Emmanuel Macron
décline les métropoles et le désert
français la France c'est sans un
département 35000 communes 68 millions
d'habitants et la République c'est aussi
et surtout l'égalité des droits et des
chances partout et pour tous
merci
[Applaudissements]